le département des yvelines comme 50
autres vient de passer au niveau orange
de l' alerte canicule
là nous sommes en alerte niveau 3 donc
les personnes à protéger en priorité
sont les bébés et les personnes âgées
les températures atteignent jusqu'à 36
degrés pour la journée de mercredi
pas forcément agréable de manger en
terrasse aujourd'hui on déjeune à
l'intérieur
en période de canicule il est plus que
recommandé de rechercher la fraîcheur de
bien s'hydrater de bien protéger les
personnes les plus vulnérables enfants
et personnes âgées pour les bébés le
chapeau les lunettes de soleil sont
obligatoires métro est possible d'agir
short tee-shirt et surtout les
rafraîchir avec un linge mouillé ou une
eau thermale pour les personnes âgées il
est important de fermer ses volets de
rester dans une pièce fraîche et
climatisées et de bien boire
la bouteille enfin il est important
d'éviter de faire du sport à cause de la
chaleur et de la pollution